i do think people underestimate
how much misery schedules bring to your
life
like uh i see a lot of very successful
wealthy people who just have busy
calendars and sometimes i get guilty of
it too and i fill up my calendar but
there's there's nothing that brings me
as much joy and happiness as an empty
calendar where you can just be
spontaneous with your day doesn't mean
you don't do anything but you just do
the things that are important and that
you want to do as opposed to be going
through a day of obligation
yeah i think that's a good like
intermediate threshold uh daniel vasalo
was on here earlier and he said like
kind of something similar he's like i
basically rearranged my life priorities
as soon as i realized that i could
have all my time back and not change too
much about my materials yeah i just i
said basically like you want a 100 free
time
that's the goal it's like 24 hours of
free time a day and once you have that
then you you have time so then you can
start spending that time towards and all
of the other things you might want to do
but i think a a shared goal for almost
everybody is to basically have 24 hours
of free time a day like that seems
reasonable
yeah one model that might be helpful
just joel people awake on that is
and i make this up i read this somewhere
unfortunately i don't remember the
original author but uh we're all born
time billionaires and we just get poorer
with time as we go on and on and on as
we spend our time you know warren
buffett probably is a time millionaire
and i'll bet you he really wishes he
could be a time billionaire but the time
billions are gone and what's left are
the money billions but he can't trade
those back for time ask any rich person
uh you know how much money they would
give up to be 10 years younger and i
think most of the same ones would tell
you all of it
i mean ultimately that's the thing you
can't leverage it's the only thing you
can't leverage is time
uh i think another tip is just don't
don't consume [ __ ]
like don't spend your time like
consuming a bunch of crap like so many
people complain about how little free
time they have and how busy they are and
then they tell me like the intricate
details of game of thrones and i'm not
saying this to be holier than thou like
i just happen to not care as much
but you just have you know ultimately
like there is time in lots of places
like if you actually break down 24 hours
a day
it can be a lot of time
uh yeah i don't think i don't have time
is is another way of saying it's just
not a priority right it's just you want
to spend your time the way you want to
spend it and if you want to be
productive then yeah don't i actually
think watching
movies tv news sports it's largely a
waste of time video games largely a
waste of time not to say i didn't do it
i spent large portions of my life
watching all of those things and playing
tons of video games but at some point or
another i just started viewing them as a
waste of time honestly i've read a ton
of fiction books and i now view most
fiction books as a waste of time it's
very hard for me to engage in fiction
because i'm just like alright cut the
chase tell me tell me what the new
interesting thing to learn is um because
i just read too many of them i'll
recognize the storyline the archetype i
can kind of see where it's headed and i
just have a hard time caring about these
fictional characters because i myself am
too conscious of my semi-fictional life
where i'm dying one second at a time and
i have no time left i don't have time to
read about this person who doesn't exist
to learn some life lesson that either
already know or i can learn more simply
elsewhere
time is literally everything it's
incredibly precious
there's there's nothing more precious
than time literally
this is maybe a weird question for like
anybody but you but like
you have at least financially like total
control over your time right and
no obligations necessarily and
it sounds like like not a preference for
a lot of like you know not infant
appetite for recreation or fiction just
like
and a deep appreciation for what that
time is you know i've heard you say that
like a number of times and it resonates
and i like but what do you do with
this time like
that's so precious clubhouse
what no what whatever i feel like in
that moment
and it can be a waste of time according
to somebody else's definition but
whatever i feel like in that moment is
the right thing for me to do
and that's what i aspire to i'm not
saying that's where i am most of the
time but that is what i aspire to and
most of my
desires are fairly mundane you know it's
play with the kids it might be go make
an investment it might be brainstorm
from startup it might be
learn something new it might be read a
book it might be go for a run you know
it's all the same stuff everybody else
does
but i just want to be able to do what i
want when i want that's all
and and by the way but by by most
people's definition i might just be
wasting a lot of time like i just right
before i got in this clubhouse i was
socializing and i was playing with my
kids right that's not quote-unquote
productive time but it's what i wanted
to do at that moment i don't do a lot of
conscious planning or if i do it sort of
falls apart anyway i i just find life is
a lot better if it's live spontaneously
obviously i have that luxury now so i
can do that but i read some tweet today
someone was basically saying like if you
had all the money in the world
um and if you would travel to all the
places you know you would want to travel
to what would you do with your life
and i reflect that for a second it's
like yeah it's basically what i'm
already doing in my life so by every
possible definition i have enough and
yet and yet and yet
um you know there was a day a couple of
months back where i was sitting on a
beach and it was a beautiful beach you
know caribbean powder caribbean style
not actually in the caribbean but powder
white sand and you know beautiful warm
ocean and i'm sitting there as a nice
breeze and there's a sunset and i'm just
kind of hanging out there and everything
was perfect with the world right and
this is the point where i is the author
and i'm supposed to have some epiphany
about how great life is and how i should
be grateful but that's not what happened
instead i realized actually
the thoughts that are going through my
head my mood the quality of my life is
exactly the same as when i'm sitting in
my living room or when i'm sitting in my
bedroom and on my ipad or i'm just
meditating i'm just walking around and
i'm just looking out the window or i'm
talking to somebody it was no better no
worse
being in this highly privileged position
didn't really in a situation didn't
actually change anything
so it really is true that your worldview
is your world it's it's just a single
player game going on inside your head
there can be for example five of us are
here talking tonight and we're all
having roughly the same experience we're
staring at our phone and we're engaging
in a conversation in clubhouse and i
assume that all of us are relatively
warm and clothed and fed and comfortable
yet the internal quality of our minds
and lives is completely different you
can have two people walking down the
street one's really happy one's really
unhappy but they're actually in the same
physical environment having roughly the
same experience
so it's really all about mindset and
mind control if your mind is out of
whack your life is out of whack
um i don't know where i was going with
this but it's all an internal game it's
all single player and yeah making more
money beyond a very early point doesn't
actually change anything in your mindset
you know there's definitely
a threshold where you need to get to
where you're relatively comfortable
and there are multiple checkpoints like
obviously if you don't have to show up
to work anymore if you're semi-retired
either because you're doing something
you love or because you made enough
money
or just because that's how you live your
life and you just chose to live without
money and
you know even without doing work which
is perfectly valid
then
you have a lot of flexibility and it
gives you another
another improvement point in your life
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
you